Hello Everybody! My name is Markiplier
And welcome to Moirai.
Now, don't be thrown off by the simplistic nature of this game
and that slightly unsettling priest standing over there,
This game is overwhelmingly positively rated on steam.
It has over 5000 reviews
and a 96% rating,
so there must be something good about this
And I'm gonna get to the bottom of it!
So I played games like this before
That are pixelated graphic
And seem  seem to be very obviously simple but
Okay. Thank you.
Oh, hello oh man! Kid you ain't look so good
Oh really, are you mama? Woahoh!
Wow, this is a secluded town where no one gets to do anything?
How does anything happen here?
There is only four homes!
Hello! Woo!
Well! Ain't that lovely!
I think this is the house I am looking for
Aaah! The beds are rolled up into the walls
How convenient
Well that's probably Julia and her now passed husband
What was that?
Oh okay! That was me. Okay.
So Julia isn't in her home and I don't..
Oh hey!
Okay! Alright, you have a fun day then girl...
One of these house's must be mine, unless I can only imagine I am the only..
Oh Woahahahahah, hi
Well, really? A little boy, much like Julia's lost little boy?
I'll talk to the Priest again in a second, I just wanna
Haaaay big man, How are you doing?
How are you doing small head
Yeah that's what, that's what normal people need
Spend time on the wild
Why is it my job? Why am I responsible for this Julia?
I have no idea
Okay...
Farm
That's an informative sign-
Hello, hi
Hehe, alright that's..
Do I get an achievement for poking all the sheep?
Oh, that one was particularly angry.
Okay, so none of these sheep are Julia
I determined that through careful selection process
Door is locked to the barn
So I can only assume that I need to go over yonder way
Where I saw something
Oh hello, hi
Are you the guy cutting wood
Oh okay, why didn't your brother take the lantern?
You think that would be something important when
When you would go into the cave
Ohh boy...
Hello, oh wai- oh hi
Geez
Alright...
Alright, thank you I am just gonna go in now
Alright, You have anything else pertinent to say
Alright
Baai?
See you later
Oh boy, looks like I got a choice
Oh it's gonna be a maze-like cave
Who made this cave
(Unsettling noises)
Hi...
Who's there?
Ohh
Hi!
Woaah...
I see you
HI!!
You wanna fight?!
Eugh...
*Markiplier's trademark laugh*
Whaaat?!
(laughing) What the hell are you talking about?
Yeah, you don't seem suspicious at all?
Oh Go- oh God
Oh oh no
I think I done did a mistake
That might have been bad
Oh boy, what even is this game?
Is this some sort of meta thing
(more unsettling noises)
Okay okay
Hi!
oh
OH
O H
Oh man
Oh man...
Oh maaan!
What do I do? She's probably gonna die anyway
but how did she get-
Injured in the first place?
Was it that guy?
I am gonna go get help
*Spurts blood at me* Thank you?
(disturbed laughter)
What is happening here?
Alright, ok
Am I gonna go to the town and find out everybody has been
MURDERED?!
Ohoho nohoho
What have I dun
Hi
hello you're new
(Mark starts to realise what's going on)
Oh...
A woman spat blood at me?
Someone gave it tooo me.
I'm getting help!
What?
WHAT?!
*WHAT?!?!*
WHAT?!?!?!?
Oh my GOHAHAD
I had no idea!
Hahaho noo
Oh that's so cool!
I had no idea!
I had, I had so many ideas how that game was gonna end
I did not think that was gonna be it!
What the fuck??
Oh maan!
Oh man, that was so cool!
It's an endless loop it doesn't matter what you do,
that's not what the game's about!
Holy
shit...
Oh man, enough freaking out about that
That is really cool, this game is free on steam
If you guys wanna try it for yourself
I highly recommend it, but now
I guess the twist has been spoiled but
You still get to determine the fate of everyone who comes before you
So, anyway check it out I will put a link in the description below
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!!